new in theaters this weekend the
predator a simple favor and white boy
Rick what will you see this is your
weekend ticket has been too quiet lately
let's bring back the best hunters in the
universe said no one ever
but hey it's happening this weekend and
you should check it out in this newest
installment of the predator series the
alien hunters return but with super
awesome genetic alterations that make
them even more better at hunting humans
and maybe each other lucky for us the
fate of humans lies in the hands of a
dysfunctional team of ex soldiers okay
this movie is for you if you often
reminisce about the original predator
movies you're in the mood for some
sci-fi action this weekend or if you
ever think we're aliens read lots I
don't know your personal life Blake
Lively and Anna Kendrick in one movie
it's like a Gossip Girl pitch perfect
universe mashup a simple favor comes out
this weekend mysterious young mom Emily
played by Blake Lively and mommy blogger
Stephanie played by Anna Kendrick become
best friends through their kids but then
Emily goes missing mystery and intrigue
ensue this movie has a real gone girl
meets big little lies bye to it a simple
favor is for you if you like dramatic
thriller mysteries you're a fan of Blake
Lively abour Anna Kendrick oh you think
the simple favor of finding your missing
friend is on the same level as passing
the salt which can also be complicated
depending on the size of the table
did you hear Matthew McConaughey lost
his entire left side it's okay though
he's alright alright alright
white boy Rick comes out this weekend
and is based on the true story of
Richard worship jr. a fifteen-year-old
who rose to the top of the 1980 Detroit
drug scene and became an FBI informant
talked about multitasking this movie is
for you if you like true crime dramas
gritty and McConaughey is your favorite
McConaughey or you miss the eighties
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see check back next week for the
house with a clock in its walls why is
the clock and its walls and not on its
walls you'll have to tune in next week
to find out
[Music]
[Music]